[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
the escort on either side of the gun
carriage formed by
first battalion grenadier guards you'll
notice that their arms are reversed
swords are turned backwards
the rifles turn back
with the left arm to hold the muscle
down all
as an act of respect for the late queen
[Music]
[Music]
the garrison sergeant major mr stokes
who has been preparing these soldiers
leads the king
and his siblings and other members of
the royal family
and then the rear rank of
that family the
earl of snowden and the duke of
gloucester
[Music]
the scarlet tunics of the dismounted
lifeguards from the household cavalry
regiment
leading this parade as the senior
regiment of the british army
[Music]
and watch from the end where buckingham
palace stand by the great statue of
queen victoria
one late sovereign watches
our latest departed queen
make her way towards
westminster the heart
of the nation's constitution
[Music]
one might surmise that the late queen
would
most have her interest
in the horses taking part
after a lifetime loving
anything equestrian
she made the point that
the king's troop who convey her now with
their horses
and their gun carriage
would keep the name her father had given
of king's troop royal horse artillery
they held that title all through her
reign
and now
we have a new king
[Music]
so
[Music]
at the center of the imperial state
crown
there are four pearl earrings that hang
from the arches where they cross
these are supposed to have come
from scotland
and to have been worn once by
mary queen of scots
[Music]
so
[Music]
and the blue sapphire in the cross at
the top
supposedly taken from the
ring finger of
king edward the confessor when his
coffin was translated
from one part of westminster abbey to
the other by king henry iii in the 1200s
i'm watching with eminent pride as their
daughter passes by queen elizabeth the
queen mother as we remember her and king
george the sixth
[Music]
the procession will shortly turn towards
the right
and pass
into horse guards by way of horse guards
approach road
[Music]
for the king taking on
the sovereign responsibility
at the death of his mother
must add a great burden to these first
days of kingship
[Music]
so
the united kingdom flags that adorn the
entire length of the mall give way
in horse guards to the flags of
commonwealth countries including
the other realms of which the queen was
sovereign head
and sovereign
and of the commonwealth itself which was
the heart of so much
that she dedicated her reign to support
[Music]
so
[Music]
it was on this corner
in 1981
that the queen was riding to her
birthday parade trooping the color
and someone with a starting pistol fired
shots towards her
no one necessarily knew it was just a
starting pistol and it
it's a reminder of
the courage that must sometimes be
required in public life to
always be at the center
of public events but the queen very
quickly recovered her horse and with
immense composure
took the entire parade
as colonel in chief
of the regiment trooping its color
[Music]
the queen consort
princess of wales
the countess of wessex and fawfa
and the duchess of sussex leave the
palace and will
pass up
bird cage walk and into
parliament square
and a light in
palace yard outside
westminster hall awaiting the arrival
of the cortege bringing
the lake queen
[Music]
queen elizabeth ii was born on the
21st of april 1926.
[Music]
and april being a bad month for weather
normally in the united kingdom
she also used to have an official
birthday
in the early weeks of june
and always that was marked
with the queen's birthday parade here
in horse guards
and as she passes through our memories
can go back to the countless times on
horseback at the side of her father the
king or as sovereign or in carriage in
later years
she took that salute from her household
division
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
passing under horse guards arch marks
the departure from the
royal grounds and
this was always the main entrance of the
palaces
and those palaces
bit the queen well on this her last
public engagement
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the blue sashes that members of the
world family wear the
most noble order of the garter
in this case given to each of them
by the queen
as the order's sovereign head
[Music]
procession turning left into whitehall
and towards parliament square
they will shortly pass the entrance to
10 downing street
and for the queen's constitutional life
she appointed
14 prime ministers inheriting one
in
sir winston churchill her 15th when
she arrived
as sovereign
[Music]
the queen unveiled this
women at war memorial
with the clothes hanging on it
that were worn by women
helping in the war effort or fighting
themselves
from 1939 to 1945 of course
in 1945
the queen herself as princess elizabeth
joined the army in the
auxiliary territorial force
and in that service she
provided her small part
towards the defeat of the tyranny
in nazi germany
[Music]
and at the rear of this procession
the blues and royals
who also form part of the household
cavalry dismounted
bringing
the rear of this procession
[Music]
last november the queen was unable to
take part in the annual act of
remembrance at the cenotaph
but she had been to almost every annual
remembrance
and she had stood in front of the center
of
beside her father too
her own wartime memories
merged with those of new generations
as so many of her armed forces served
on operations during her reign
[Music]
at its top the cenotaph has the empty
tomb for the thoughts and memories of
all those
families who were affected by war
[Music]
so
[Music]
the dead of wars
acknowledging
in silence
the sovereign
whose father and grandfather led them in
the first and second world war
and so many of those who died
during the queen's reign
in the army
navy and air force
[Music]
around the gun carriage the
military aquarius who served the queen
from the royal navy the army and the air
force
taking their
place as pallbearers for the sovereign
they served
whilst
first battalion grenadier guards march
on either side of them
guarding
elizabeth ii
[Music]
band of the scots
guards who have
[Music]
carried out this task today
with their director of music
[Music]
and the major general commanding the
household division major general chris
geeker
whose troops including these the king's
troop royal horse artillery
are playing their part in saluting
this former sovereign
[Music]
the queen's personal staff marching in a
row there the
palace steward two of her pages
[Music]
they would have been in close attendance
on the queen
day by day throughout her life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the queen passes the statue of sir
winston churchill
as she enters now
parliament square
with a royal salute from the guards of
honor
the procession will turn into that great
palace yard and we can see
[Music]
the massive hall of westminster waiting
to greet the late sovereign
and we'll witness
as she is taken from the gun carriage
and carried into the heart of that hall
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]